this world is not yet ready for all that  you will do  your time will come diana  and everything will be different  citizens of the world i'm here to change  your life  anything you want  [Music]  anything you dream of you can have it  look like you saw a ghost  diana lucky you it's like not one day  has passed  i don't want to be like i want to be an  apex predator  you've always had everything while  people like me have had nothing  well now it's my turn  get used to it  i've never been one for rules the answer  is always more  the way i fly they will never find us i  forgot to tell you  what raider will they will they shoot at  [Music]  us  barbara what did you do  you know i'm not so keen on this one i  figure uh you are but  you know what i'm ready to go i think we  can do better  parachute pants yeah um does everybody  parachute now